das heißt spezielle spritzen sind
sozusagen der schlüssel dafür mehr
impfstoff dann tatsächlich nutzen zu
können wie schwierig ist es an diese
spritzen ran zu kommen könnte dass
eigentlich jeder arzt in deutschland
machen
das ist sehr schwierig an diese spritzen
heranzukommen weil es eigentlich jungs
unternehmen ist die ein patent ihres
vaters letztendlich jetzt vermarkten
es ist damals entstanden bei arbeiten
über spritzen die ins auge appliziert
werden da werden kleine mengen sehr
genau injiziert und insofern waren dafür
besondere spritzen notwendig dass sich
das seinerzeit patentieren lassen
und es ist jetzt von drei brüdern im
prinzip in holland dann auf den markt
gebracht worden dort laufen auch einige
pilotprojekte und nachdem es nicht
gelungen war die familie zu kontaktieren
und mir dann auch mehrere proben von
spritzen zur verfügung gestellt und dann
hat sich sehr schnell herausgestellt
dass man deutlich gut und eigentlich
jedes mal sieben dosen pro weil ziehen
kann
maier wenn wir eine ganz einfache
rechnung aufmachen wir holen jetzt mehr
raus bedeutet das dass die menschen
weniger impfstoff bekommen oder bedeutet
das dass wir sonst vergessen so hoch
wertvollen gut einfach kleine mengen
wegschmeißen müssen
normalerweise haben wir in letzter zeit
sonst kleine mengen weggeschmissen weil
die anstatt rechnung geht so wenn man
konzentrierten impfstoff von 0,45
milliliter den verdienen sie mit
kochsalzlösung in der menge von 1,8
millimeter das ist im gesamtergebnis
dann ein gelöster impfstoff von 2,25
milliliter wenn sie das durch 0,3
dividieren kommen sie auf die zahl 7,5
das heißt also mit den spritzen wird
dich weniger ausgezogen sondern es wird
wirklich die geforderte menge von 0,3
millimeter ausgenutzt verbleibt dann
immer noch einen rest von einer halben
spritze mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dir das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren